Hey Youtubers it's Charlie. Thank you everyone
that submitted questions for my GoT
Q&A today
Lot's of questions about where things are
going based on changes they made so
I tried to include as many non spoilery
things as possible. I also saw a lot of
Brienne jokes.
So just as we get into it, careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen
it yet.
I think my favorite joke was when Sansa
got mad at Brienne and for being at
Joffery's wedding.
In her defence, it's not her fault. She
wasn't there in the books.
So here we go, first question. Kaiser Red asks,
"Why doesn't Brienne mention the fact
that Aria lives to Sansa?
Because everyone else thinks
she's dead." I think that she probably
just forgot and the writers probably
excluded that because they felt it
would create more problems in the
narrative of the episode.
This is one of those logic issues.
Normally you would expect that Brienne
would say, "Hey your sister's still alive!"
And maybe that would entice Sansa to go with her and
then they go to track down Arya.
But that would pull the story in a
vastly different direction than the
writers wanna go.
So the convenient thing to do is just
exclude it. Just make Brienne forget to
mention it.
As much as it seems weird you have to
remember that Briane is a normal person
and think about all the times you talk
to your friends and you just you forget
to mention things.
So if you really want to nitpick you
could chalk it up to that, but really I
think the writers just excluded it because
they didn't want to pull the story in a
different direction.
Next question: Nick asks, "Could you do a
video explaining the Martell family like
why they're called princes?" I assume you mean
when the rest of the people in Westeros are
called lords and like there's only one
king,
so why are the Martells called princes? The
Martells are part of the Seven Kingdoms so
technically (like in a hierarchy)
they are lords but
its are Rhoynar tradition to call
yourself a prince so they give
themselves the prince / princess titles
for cultural reasons. It doesn't give
them extra power,
it's just that they're upholding traditions
of their ancestors. I may have explained in a
previous video, but
Princess Nymeria was a Rhoynar princess
when the Valyrians invaded
their homeland in the east.
She led them across the land bridge and
created what is now modern day Dorne.
So when people talk about Rhoynar traditions
they're talking about those people.
Next question: Chris asks,"What do you
think the significance of Drogon
sniffing Danny's hand
and flying away is?" Well I think that they
included that just to show that the
Dragons haven't lost their bond with the
Daenerys.
Drogon is still bonded to her even
though he's flying free.
It's a contrast to Rhaegal and Viserion
who
are chained up beneath the pyramid and
going crazy. Dan and Dave just don't want
you to be confused and think that the
dragons have completely turned on her.
They haven't, like the dragons that are
chained up are just really pissed.
Daenerys also made it seem like Drogon
had left for good, so
it's just a reminder the Drogon is
not gone for good. It's like he's just
checking in with Mom before he goes
off and has some more fun.
Next question: Kevin asks, "I think John Snow will
have to learn that he is actually a
Stark before
he'll accept Stanis' offer to legitimize him."
Well technically I think he does know
that he is a Stark.
He think's that Ned is his father so that
would make him a Stark,
it's just that he thinks his mother is some
other commoner.
I talk all the time about how I think
that his real mother is Leanna Stark
and his real father is Rhaegard Targaryen.
That would give him very pure royal
blood
but in the line of succession, he'd still
be viewed as something of a bastard.
You can also view bastards as children
born out the line of succession.
So like during the Targaryen civil war,
during the Dance of the Dragons (that the
spin-off story that George RR Martin wrote)
There were Targaryens in the direct line
of succession they were having children
out of wedlock with other Targaryens so
technically they're bastards
even though they have pure Targaryen
royal blood. It gets a little messy so
I think we'll have to wait to see the
show deals with that in it how they
explain it.
But what I'm hoping is the George RR Martin
what will spell this out in greater
detail
in Winds of Winter so we'll actually have
some canon to go on.
Right now it's all conjecture. Next
question: Element Studios asks,
"Since all of the Faceless men are no one,
do you think the Jaqen H'ghar is more or
less a pseudonym
that they give to the Many Face God
like a mantle that all Faceless Men
wear?"
So you're asking like is that a name that
they just pass around?
No I just think that's just the name that he
chose for the mission he was on when he
met Arya.
It's a little fuzzier in the books so I'm
going to focus more on the show's interpretation.
The reason I think that they're still
calling him Jaqen H'ghar on the show
it just for simplicity's sake, just
so that viewers don't get confused.
What Jaqen H'ghar is trying to tell Arya is
that he has no true identity.
He takes on any identity that he needs
based on the missions that he goes on.
Just to take it a step further though
identity is a big deal this season like,
'Who are you? Do you have royal blood even
though you think you're a bastard?
Or in the case of Arya, can you leave
your identity behind?
As characters evolve through the next
couple of seasons, you'll see their
identities change although you know, I
think that
you know by the end everyone will return
to baseline.
But what I'd really like to see in the
finale is like you know you this big
journey
but then they all come back together and
it's like a bunch of Starks versus
a bunch of White Walkers. Next question:
Jake asks, "Can people from the UK use
HBO NOW?"
So you do actually have version of HBO
NOW through your cable provider I think
the people that broadcast HBO
internationally like they may call it
something different but there are
simulcasts happening across the world.
If you do live outside the United States
and you're not sure whether or not you
have access to simulcast through your
cable provider
just check on their website they'll
probably say there. HBO NOW is just the
name of the simulcast service
that Apple paid a premium to get. HBO
signed other streaming deals with other
providers
but they had to call it something
different. The funny twist is
is that Apple only paid for the HBO NOW
name,
they didn't pay for exclusive rights to
simulcast. So yes there are simulcast
outside the United States. Legitimate! Not
pirate streams.
Next question: Maaike asks, "What kind
of a role do you think that Kevan
Lannister will play?"
Well so he said he was heading back to
Casterly Rock so I don't think that we're
gonna see him for a while.
I think Cersei will take care of
herself like she'll be her own worst
enemy for the next couple of episodes.
I do that Kevan will come back but if you have
read the books I think they'll just
cut out
a lot of his book story. But thematically
a lot of it will still be there.
Next question: Matt asks, "Is Doran Martell
ever going to get up
and start seeking revenge to avenge his
brother?" Yes.
He has like a very specific revenge plot
he's much more calculating than the
Sand Snakes.
Ellaria Sand is just way more
trigger-happy. Doran Martell is like the
real master planner
that's why they call it the Dornish
Master Plan. I don't know how many
episodes he's
in this season, but I don't think that
we'll start to see that master plan
play out until he's on screen again. And even
if it does happen they could push in the
season six so we we might not learn more
about it till like way way later this
season.
Next question: Marcus asks, "Do you think
that Tristan Martell will end up playing
Quentyn's role?"
So for those that haven't read the
books, they're like other Martell's
that they just cut out of the show.
No I don't think that Tristan is going to do
any Quentyn stuff. I think they've just
completely cut that stuff out.
Because George RR Martin has so many
other characters in the books that the
show has just had to exclude
you have people going all over the world
doing things that just we won't ever see
on the show.
That's why sometimes when i'd I try to
explain stuff I'll say you know if you
haven't read the books
don't worry about XYZ plot because it
doesn't matter.
Whenever they do release Winds of
Winter, I'll do some more like specific book
related videos. Most of the time I try to
make these videos more about the show
but sometimes it helps to reference the
books if it adds some more context to
what's going on.
Next question: Evil Grim asks, "When are
going to Bran Stark?
His story just started to get interesting
last season." So the way Dan and Dave
explained it
his story is just like in a place it's like
so far ahead of the other
characters
they're just not ready to go forward with
him. I think his story gets more tied up
with the war with the White Walkers
and we haven't even seen White Walkers yet
this season. I think that'll start to
play out when we get up to Hardhome.
So once we get into that I think we'll
see some White Walkers and then in
season 6 Bran will come back.
And he'll be necessary because it's like,
'Oh, look at this army of White Walkers!
We're right near this giant forest. We
someone who has power over nature to
help us out.'
Thank you so much everyone for so
many questions. These are always a ton of fun to do.
And thank you everyone for being good
with the spoilers I know some of you
you know, watched the leaked episodes it's
okay I don't mind people commented on that
stuff as long as they use like liberal
spoiler tags.
Just because they're a lot of people
that don't want to hear about that stuff.
Big thank you to everyone contributing
subtitles too thank you so much that's
been such a huge help.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Metal Tester.
You win a subscription to HBO Now. It's
basically like a iTunes gift card because
you have to buy HBO Now through the Apple store.
Just DM me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact info.
Just a reminder too the people that won
the books the signed copies of George RR
Martin's books
no one has contacted me about that yet.
If no one contacts me in the next couple
of weeks
I'll just roll them out for new giveaway.
Technically as of right now you
still have a chance to win signed copies
of George RR Martin's books.
My schedule in the next couple days is
going to be a little bit weird I'm
seeing an early screening of Avengers Age
of Ultron as part of this like special
marathon
so try to keep you guys updated you can
follow me on Twitter and Facebook
for updates on on what's going on with
videos and stuff.
If you don't know how to find me there
there links at the bottom the
description. But while you guys wait for
the rest of my videos this week you can
click here for my episode 2 video if you
haven't seen it yet and you can click
here to learn all about the house of
black and white. Thank you so much
for watching everybody!
Lets high five! I'll see you guys tonight.